[Musique]
dans la tête et compagnie avec ta musique
[Applaudissements]
ma musique n'a pas de force
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on regarde les albums de l'amitié non
le paiement vient de commencer
[Applaudissements]
la différence colombie j'aime
et non seulement j'aime mon peuple et que
La Bolivie est partie, nous ne les avons plus jamais abaissés
nous nous sommes arrêtés de sotrobal aujourd'hui où est mon
les gens ma famille
mon nom est mon peuple oui oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
Choses
parfois c'est valable
[Applaudissements]
Oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus
une fille liée une fille qu'ils donnent
[Applaudissements]
adieu
oh
Merci
et donc
[Applaudissements]
Alors